you guys ever seen those videos where
they ask the girls like okay what's your
ideal gu and they'll be like6 feet
[Laughter]
[Music]
$300,000 welcome back to a very
important episode of care boys we going
to determine something that uh could be
world changing for a lot of us all right
would you if you could would you trade
inches off your dick for inches in
height or Versa or vice versa I say if
you got 2 in above 6 feet you can
definitely do it are you 6' to
that's how about you go three
in no no no no I can't do that can't do
that I got to be a little bit above
average you know got to be a little bit
what about this or cuz that's just like
taking two inches off my hair and then
I'm good bro here's the thing though but
like once you're once you're six once
you're 5'11 dude you're practically 6
foot no bro
that's like weing fake
Jordan but most people won't know dude
can I lose weight and increase girth
that's what would be cool you want to do
that in addition to I want to lose if
you lose your weight this way it
increases your but hole doing he's
talking that's benefiting both ways I
know I want a thicker dick but a smaller
belly I feel where the sacrifice I feel
like that's very large that's very
because he's thinking look you're taking
height and then adding length and now
we're taking weight and adding girth
that's true yeah I like your logic so or
would you Brazilian dick
LIF make your dick skinnier and then
become fat hey you know there's actually
a video of three Chinese guys who wants
that who wants a skinnier penis there's
a video of three Chinese guys pulling uh
a semi trck with their dicks three of
them yo man dick fu is real man like
tied to the dick and they're they're
like H and like pulling it like yeah I
don't know if I can
what love they love doing that [__] huh
real they'll have [__] logs just
slamming their dicks it's called
chis
chis dude if you get shirts man I'll
wear them chis might be these
guys I like the idea of just Googling
dick Kung Fu dick kung fu yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
them do they have a traveling show oh
they're [__] I don't know how you're
doing it so this is um I wonder if it it
stretches it like permanently damn that
got to I love how they put like their
sweaters they tie it on top so they
can't you think one of them's yelling at
the other like pull your weight's dude
that truck is moving with their dicks
with their dicks wow that's
inappropriate
dude that was punching a stomach dude
that thing you like kid yeah it's a kid
is that a kid you like that I wonder how
it's tied so would you do it would you
do one of these or one of these yeah
answer the question Joe i o one of the
other
think I'm five I think 57 to 59 it's 2
in right yeah two it's not a big
difference okay okay maybe we can ask K
so I'll go shorter and I'll make a dick
bck not just kidding do you prefer girth
or length yeah you're going to cut off
some of your height in order to get a
longer dick
yeah Anthony how how so so say if you're
you have your man right what would you
want him to do well how what would you
add hold on I I have questions what
would you add just answer the question
it's a simple question simple question
it's not hard dude it's not that simple
you don't need you don't need to know
more parameters just answer the question
I think it depends where they start
that's what I was going to ask thank you
cuz if they're if they're starting at a
micropenis then you just have a thick
nub okay exactly it's a [__] at that
point okay we're starting with 4 in you
want a [__] obviously dude you know the
answer to that so 4 in either it gets
girthier or no no not girth length
length with a sacrifice of height 55 oh
yeah yeah we can we can but he's 5'5 but
he's 5'5 and he has a 4 in penis no no
he's
53 or he's 3 in dude I feel like both
scenarios are pretty shitty that's tough
dude so you got a lengthen one 53 with a
7 in dick or 57 with a 3 in dick you
guys are saying too many numbers bro get
confused I don't know what's going on we
need a we need a whiteboard somewhere
let's just make it let's make it easy
I'm a visual person 5 five and five all
right he's 5 five is Dick is 5 in okay
plus or minus which way would you want
either of those things would you want
more height more dick yeah that's a good
question that's a conundrum so then
he'll be a 3in dick yeah or he'll be a
or seven but he's 53 or or or a 10 if
you wanted to be that small oh [__] he's
doing five so then he'll be
53 damn do you want him to be short dude
do you love a short King is the question
no two two two minimal oh two minut you
got a baseline too help me Anthony what
kind of dick would I
want he can either be 5'7 Y what kind of
dick would you want you know what though
I don't think it's fair you didn't bro
you're trying to avoid the question you
know what you know why this isn't a fair
question okay a inch on a dick is way
more than an inch for height for Real by
ratio concept yes but that's the point
but but they say I would I would I would
take extra inches on the Dick cuz I I'll
feel it brother I'll feel that extra
can't do it guys it's a one to one ratio
but I thought I thought length didn't
matter to him because I always hear like
sometimes
that okay okay okay I'm not going to
even argu it anymore instantly shut down
unless you've experienced what I've
experienced that's not
true well tell us what you've
experienced no Nick come on dude that's
part of the fun no she said she's
experienced no
dick thank you Anthony I you come to
don't bail her out but he was 65 you
know what I mean yeah no dick but
6'5 worth it so would you want a super
tall dude with a small dick or a really
short dude with a long dick wait talking
about like a a [__] with so I'm saying
53 with an amazing dick to where it's
like oh my gosh I need to have sex with
him all the time yeah or you have a tall
guy M with a small dick and hey with a
barely knows how to work it I would take
the shorter dude with with the bigger
dick short C that's good that's good
that's a good answer make sure you have
a strong dick dude cuz that's that's
where it ends it's like you want either
nice act one or a nice act three Ah
that's good cuz it's a great first
impression I still I still want to know
the real answer the 55 5 in guy yeah
like like where do you go where do you
go so you said you said you'd be down to
turn a 55 guy into a 53 guy if he could
have a 7 in dick right yeah I guess I
would do that okay how tall are you 53
59 dick dude see you You' be okay with
like 55 5 well this is the we're not
talking about would i' be okay with
dating us somebody that short we're
talking about that specific scenario
okay don't put me in a [__] corner
and now we're putting you in a corner
since you want to make it about dating
now let's make it about dating yeah make
it about dating get her prer Nick's
really funny you guys know about that
and you really like to avoid the
question tell them tell them Co Jo get
her d y come
onen that's the question bro what's the
question answer the question what's the
question I don't do that
bro
what was the question yeah what was the
question see look this is this is her
plan it's just to get us all R up so
then we forget the question and now
we're sitting here like oh what's the
question what is the question again she
got it the question would you date a
what tall man M tall guy with a with a
small dick I already answered this I
would date somebody who would be shorter
with the bigger dick but that's your
dating preference no that's not what the
f even if we never asked her that would
be a preference now you're just put
watching all the short dudes that got
long dicks out there like let's
go I got a shot I got a shot every short
dude she sees he's like M I hope there's
something in
there you're going to have so much dick
DMS yeah dude or you can just add you
can address your preferences right now
speak to your people right now what's
your preference I don't know your
preference [__] Nick
dude all right all right how about this
just for the record what's your ideal
height and length yeah range we don't
care if he's funny guy or perfect and
circumference counts yeah that's
who give a yeah give a radius of what
you
want it's to telescope um you know how
it gets smaller and then bigger I mean
yeah my preference would be somebody
who's taller than me so what's the range
what's the range so somebody who's 511
and 51 51 she's basically saying six
foot she's basically saying just say six
foot ad Jon okay so why even answer the
questions if you're just going to speak
for me you're saying well I'm just
trying to put I know I'm just trying to
put your what you're saying into reality
shut up cool
Jo so Colleen saying she wants a guy
that's taller than her with a way bigger
dick yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah now
you're just asking for too much yeah I
am all right what's the what's the you
guys ever seen those videos where they
ask the girls like okay what's your
ideal guy and they'll be like 6t
$300,000 those goals are unrealistic
because they're talking about like the
0.1% of people but they did say ideal
dream right so it's like and magically
that guy has all the time cuz my track
record is showing that I'm realistic
yeah you've dated some pretty short some
short guys short G that means they had
some long dick probably they had they
had their dick was as long as this knife
and I'm not talking about without the
handle with the handle that's black
too we're all thinking it we're all but
you got to get it from the right angle
of girth otherwise you're like oh [__]
it look short that's what I'm saying you
guys already know my preference why am I
asking what's your preference no what's
your would you sacrifice some of your
height which you have a lot of I think
context is very important okay so uh
because of my current situation I would
cut off 2 in of my my height the reason
why is because I'm already married she's
already stuck with me I might as well
start changing her life right now that's
you think she and she's short I like
that that's a man's answer you're not
selfish so from that was so brave of you
dude I was so
brave you sit on the side of the table
you your wow that was [__] Brave dude
does that mean does that mean Nina can
handle a big dick or is it going to hurt
her cuz she's short and small I is going
to hurt her she's going to adapt she's
going to adapt I think I'm just going to
take her to outer space is all right now
she's still
local right now she's still in like you
know LA and I need to send her outside
the the planet she's going to have an
out of body
experience all the time now this is cool
don't say this to NE oh by the way hi hi
Mom she watches too anyway oh God that's
awkward then there's also the fact that
you know like I'm I'm significantly
taller than her so our photos will look
a little nicer yeah that's cool that's
cool yeah but this is an easy answer
Anthony because when you have the height
you can easily when you got some height
to spare but you are going to lose your
six foot card okay what about you three
but I have I have had it for you know
many years of my adult life already so
it's okay now I don't think I can
sacrifice any more height
man and I need in the middle 1 in 1 in
that's perfect too minimum too minimum
dude all right fck it I'll go
shorter that's a good how T are you you
look shorter right
now you look like you're doing something
El longer yeah dud I can see it from
here holy
[__] I'll go shorter on a dick oh on the
Dick yeah good for hey good for you Joe
stand for him good for you Joe what a
brave guy that is too long
yeah it's too long to in the way he ends
up he ends up 63 like damn dude you had
that much to give I don't want to I
don't want to dick reduction yeah I want
customization oh like what what do you
want to do now you're changing the rules
dude I think if I had a big head I want
to be you know you don't like your ratio
no because when you see dildos you go oh
it's shaped like that for a reason it's
ergonomic I think it's also circumcised
Joe I could peel it back and make it
look circumcised so
there so like some dildos they're like
shaped interesting they like got the
veins on the side and the [__] big
yeah the big head so you had some mods
so I think mushroom mods so I think I
would I would go both what kind of dick
has the most feels uh-huh yeah yeah and
then for me you have like a rib
dick you put some Anal beans on it well
it it would have to go like want the
little urch it has to be veiny with a
mushroom top so you can get everything
cuz also I I feel like all guys aren't
created the same some of us probably
have more nerve or like less nerves or
like cuz some dudes like they'll get
like rectile dysfunction and I don't
know if that's psychological or maybe
it's just sense sense is so I want the
ultimate if I could sacrifice height to
see what the ultimate dick feels like
that's what I want to do you want to see
what it feels like like you want to have
one not to get [__] by feels like to
have one don't worry Joe I got you Joe
don't let him try and play you over here
Joe I know what you mean remember when
Bart was like hey Steve can I hold your
dick hard cuz I heard you have a big
dick wait what when did he say that he
did yeah he did he's like for science he
goes I want you to get hard and then let
me grab it for science just for science
for science if you do it for science
just not get up I would can you call
Hannah and ask her what she would prefer
if your dick was bigger if you were
taller okay and in the process you
answer it oh yeah I can't afford less
dick dude then I won't have a dick you
can't afford less dick I can't afford
less dick you won't have a dick I won't
have a dick if I if I if I get taller
I'm five F I'm wearing shoes so I'm 5'8
right now 58 so you cut three 55 hello
hello I need you to answer something
it's about it's like life or death okay
all right so if okay so I could add two
Ines but I'm going to have to I'm going
to have to um take out two Ines so take
would you rather have me add 2 in to my
height but then I reduce 2 in to my dick
or would you rather have me add 2 in to
my dick and then remove 2 in of my
height oh 2 in to the dick cuz it equals
out when you're lying down
oh
okay that's an amazing answer Go Hannah
how come everyone else got it but not me
does you want me to reduce my dick no
your dick's lovely but you want me to
add more dick more dick because lying
down height doesn't
matter I'm already shorter than her
that's why so it doesn't that's why it
doesn't matter cuz I could be even more
shorter yeah okay thank you I love
you okay thank you how do you end that
conversation
right all right what do you want for
dinner tonight meanwhile she's Jun she's
like hey can I take your order she's on
the speaker phone and then just hold on
my husband's calling me yeah 2 Ines to
the dick would be am amazing laying down
like no no your dick's lovely
but
dude that was a great answer yeah
Hannah's so clever man she's a legend
damn she can say anything and I'm like
that's good I'm already shorter than her
so being even more shorter just doesn't
matter cuz I'm already
shorter she's just like can I take two
inches off my height for his
dick you can donate height yeah well
that changes everything yeah so how do
we put this for a woman so would you
take
off height to add to your boobs or take
off boobs to add more height or would
you subtract face to add to your boobs
yeah yeah what would be the what would
be the scenario for a girl like you're
just negative2 would you subtract talent
for potential your face gets less
symmetrical yeah yeah your face is two
points less attractive would it be boobs
and butt though yeah I mean that's a
that's a question for you guys cuz it
might be like height and then you you
become fat flat butt flat
butt was that Nursery r i mean flat boob
flat butt flat butt flat butt okay yeah
yeah yeah you're right yeah but I don't
think that's the same thing cuz it's
like not really so cuz girls like dick
and height right so then you have it's
like you it's one or the other so guys
like tit so you can be like okay would
you rather have boobs are ass yeah but
some guys are more of a tits guy and
some guys are more of an ass guy yeah
some girls are more of a hyp guy and
some girls are more of a dick guy that
is clearly a dick
guy I think I'm more of a dick guy
myself that's a great speed dating thing
are you more of a dick guy or a Hy guy
cuz it's one or the other yeah you can't
have both got a guy you huh
lady oh that is true it's hard the girl
equipent is hard to find so the bigger
the boobs the flatter the ass I mean it
got kind of yeah it's hard to say I
heard it's hard to like carry the but
it's for the man's pleasure that's like
the flip so trying to find that girls
don't get pleasure in having big
nothing big
nothing the word choices here today
are it's purely for science for science
we're trying to figure it out though as
we go
yeah how about like uh would you lower
your your uh your dude's monetary
earning potential for more dick oh
that's a good one like he'll never make
Beyond this cap what's the cap uh and
where do I live $10,000 less a year is
10 mm longer millime bro what the [__]
is a millimeter somebody grabbed me a
ruler this D $60,000 a year with great
dick or
$120,000 a year with bad dick I'll I'll
take great dick because I can make my
own money too whoa okay she's not the
right girl to ask for this okay okay
okay okay if you if you I'm not
answering any further questions thank
you so much n you can't no dude all
right uh Les F stop with longer
lenss let go I got what perfect dick but
no
limbs yeah dude yeah I think that's the
end of the video
we set the timer he said perfect dick no
Libs it's whatever you want it to be
it's like a guy sex toy like you know
how the sex dolls there's no limbs
they's just a torso you just have to be
ridden constantly right yeah like the
girl still going to have to do all the
work so imagine no no no no okay okay
not a perfect dick in my book imagine
you had this guy right all the work who
was the perfect like vibrator okay he
just so no limbs right wait what's the
question so imagine if you had this guy
with like perfect dick to where it's
like you know how if you if a girl uses
a vibrator it hits she knows how to hit
all her right spots at the right RPS so
if you had a guy with no want to share
Theo and he can do that every single
time would you take him but he's
homeless I mean you make your own you
even said you make he doesn't have a car
how about that you said you make your
own money so you can support both of you
guys he doesn't have a license he
doesn't have a car doesn't tip
ever he doesn't tip
so answer the question which one is it
no no to what no even if he shaped like
the rabbit just cuz he's homeless even
he turns around he goes sorry I
lied oh no dude no sorry I li wrap the
video up Nick I think we get like
squeeze five more
minutes